hello welcome to the lobby game spots
weekly hangout every tuesday at 2pm
pacific right here on cavespot.com are
you doing the chicken obviously i'm
doing the chicken dance danny
it's thematically appropriate my good
friend christopher waters hello side of
the couch and we're delighted to be
joined by greta and jason from loot
thanks you guys you've
created a game that is like the bane of
anyone who's hosting a show
because you called it fluster cluck and
you have to look at the screen
think about it don't say you gotta say
that one carefully yeah
that would be a terrible accident yeah
if you were to say that no that's that's
what we want is like we want kids to be
like mommy mommy
and you know the parents are going to be
like what we want to play what yeah yeah
fluster clock e for everyone this whole
show is a fluster clock already because
i'm
we got a bunch of uh big big boring
triple a games on later on but uh thanks
for coming on and showing a game that uh
perhaps folks don't know about this
coming out in third week of october on
playstation 4. yeah october 21st ps4 and
you want me and christopher to
immediately play it yeah let's jump
right into the gameplay gents oh yeah so
just select career
there we go select new new cool coach
class don't worry we'll see the other
classes in a sec player two press cross
to join select your ufo your gun your
hat your turret your character no
pressure you have ten seconds
where's my chicken left yeah and go for
what's in the box we're gonna unlock a
little bit
okay all right gonna be super
so depending on your personality type
you choose which character you want
there we go you're ready to go top one
right cook fried cookie yup like
yep little buddy there we go awesome
okay this is a twin stick shooter with
some resource collection it's pick up
and play so what you're gonna do left
analog stick to maneuver right analog
stick to rotate the camera r2 to shoot
the guns pick up objects with the cross
button and bring them to the chickenizer
should i be shooting more or less
getting to check it out
all right she's got lit up wait this
isn't ridiculous
that's okay you're going to turn it into
chicken okay it's the old joke why does
everything taste like chicken you're
about to find out
drop everything in the chickenizer
that's how you score points
is this ai hit hit you're playing
against one human opponent and two a i
apologize you're gonna automatically get
him yep there you go okay now you can
white guys you have your cow perfect so
you're in the league come on
come on come on you got 10 points you
can catch up to this there we go now
there's a special weapons dispenser it's
a glowing purple icon on the map where
is it find that special weapons
dispenser it's at the bottom of the map
it's a glowing float oh wait there's
more than just daddy in here fly over
here there
here we go perfect if you shoot down one
of your opponents turn him into chicken
chicken eyes him everything comes into
church everything must be turned away
from you absolutely
yeah there you go you got him nice it's
close you're in first okay there we go
oh sneaking in you got four seconds
right get some chicken come on come on
and you have been promoted to the
undercounter gum removal technician
thank you christ this is like way better
than destiny would have taken five hours
to get done paid in free gum all games
need chicken in them what do we do next
okay so i'm gonna borrow that controller
for me for a sec do it we're gonna do
something really cool here this game
is shipping with a hidden code what yes
what are you going to tell it right now
we're not going to tell you the code but
we're going to show you what the code
does okay so this code what it does is
really cool i'm going to look at your
controller was left right left right
there was uh some bus
analog sticks he drew it
this opens up the secret menu
big hat mode gotcha yeah unlock
everything yeah perfect now we're going
to show you what this game's horsepower
really has so gentlemen god mode
oh you're not ready for divine chicken
that's that comes later so now we're
gonna go into battle
we're gonna do chicken hunt this unlocks
everything in the game so we've got the
alpine level we've got the desert level
we've got burned out zombie city we've
got spaceship so we're gonna jump into a
level
and we're going to go straight to first
class it's time for our first class is
that difficulty uh actually no you can
adjust the ai's difficulty but in this
case we're all playing against each
other
so go ahead and join in i'm sorry thanks
this time i will be corny
and you got to select which which guns
you want which hat you want because all
these things change the stats like some
hats give you more damage some give you
more health more regeneration etcetera
are you guys going to be selling hats
and your ships is this team fortress
okay right now everything this game is
shipping with everything in there you
just have to unlock it in the campaign
or use the code if you want to have a
big party
yep i'm going to pick gherkin because
makes all our graphics here at gamespot
yes including the intro for the lobby
here we go
okay i'm gonna kiss this is it
free-for-all prepare to be chicken
square is the uh
special weapon when we pick up okay the
special weapons dispenser is the glowing
purple icon there's a few of them on
this map
so you pick up your special weapon
camels nice i'm out of time yes yes i'm
going to keep oh
hey
get nuked
did you notice when you used your
special weapon the sound effect of me
getting shot down actually came out of
my controller speaker because i owned
you so hard oh that is actually true you
did get it yeah get it remember no
shooting down the narrator
everyone shoot down the narrator
i saw a chicken i said i might have shot
it hey who's player four what don't
worry about it grab it just
you trade it don't worry okay you got
worked never underestimate the power of
a chick that is very true grandpa
actually wiped the floor with all of us
it was hilarious to watch okay we'll go
easy on you no problem and all of a
sudden two you know two minutes later
we're all smoking ufo wrecks i love this
vaguely arabian music that's playing
well we are in the desert level right
now right yeah
so it's like everything that's powered
by
absolutely
everything dropping the camel in the
inappropriate place player four you've
got a turret press the square button
drop that turret off it'll auto target
your enemies hey who's player two i'm
i'm just killing the people
i feel like this is like an allegory for
modern day farming and that there are no
more camels dude this is a traffic jam
on the 405 in l.a
nice
not last
very cool exactly very cool awesome
mother cluckers
that was a first-class fluster clock
right there
very nice who was purple
who was scoring more than everyone else
combined this is what we've been dealing
with we've been working on this game for
like 18 months she comes right on in and
just smokes all of us not cool
so how about this time how about 2v2
let's do teams should we do that i'm on
greta's team all right
oh i see how it is okay
i get this loser all right now we're
gonna that's okay we've got a special
talent on your
this time we're going to do some burned
out zombie city action makes the most
zombies the other other green meat
so grab your character your ufo your hat
let's jump in this one's got a shamrock
on it i don't know who has the shamrock
ship give me that [ __ ]
yes i don't want to be him i want to be
sorry gerkins [ __ ] i'm going to be
someone else yeah go for someone else
because all these characters have their
own personality magnetar obviously is
well he's not subjugating planets he's
turning everything into chickens i love
him
yeah i'm doubling down on chicken oh
okay chicken hat on my ufo chicken
inside the ufo what all right
chicken
what's that sandwich you can get it's
got the chicken on the outside danny
stop trying to distract me double down
all right grab the zombies bring them to
the chicken eyes that's how you score
points delicious chicken there's warp
pipes in this level if you find the war
pipe you might get to the chicken eyes a
little faster can't get over that stupid
wall maybe all right what special
weapons do we have player two you've got
a hell power up so oh nice [ __ ] there we
go
hey stop shooting oh i got over there
hey
there we go
come on
i got wasted nice that's right but not
before i scored
zombie pants
there we go
this is mine this is mine oh
nice player four you've got an
air-to-air missile activate with the
square button yeah hit that hit that
button need it all of you oh
nice
if you shoot someone down remember to
chickenize them player four you are a
camper sir
you have earned the special camping icon
you're in trouble you must you must get
away from the chickenizer before you
did you bring the marshmallows to make
some smallers
is this goddamn
there we go okay player two you just
deployed player three you've got a mine
i do i just put it down nice but i wish
i could shoot your mind
turn it into food
chicken eyes anything you shoot down
nice did i tell you to play who's number
one
number one
our team but remember there is a special
attack so in the event that you're
behind on points and you need to catch
up the special attack that you have to
use is very simple very straightforward
are you getting treasured now yeah
treasure chest you guys just you guys
kind of
everything can be turned into okay this
is a fluster clock
why are there zombies camels cows ufos
treasure chests why not it's a foster
clock go with it because your artists
weren't given any direction so they just
made assets for every like sure whatever
our creative leader ours in this game is
hilarious his name is remy he's
brilliant he's just every french
stereotype you can ever think of he's
great where's the croissant level it's
like i do not care about any of this you
will enjoy it you will play it what you
don't like the chicken everything is the
better irony that he's actually italian
and then you guys don't know
there we go all right somebody is about
to get a missile
oh no not me there you go
vicious yes okay and you're pulled down
nice this is payback
turret
there i picked it up
i see how it is all right hey put that
turret there okay all right nice oh okay
oh no come here i'm pretty sure laying
down artillery when someone is trying to
use a major thoroughfare is against the
california dmv
come on
convention it is against the geneva
convention
weapons of mass chickenization
all
right you got to be running out of
chicken puns soon
are you kidding me for 18. this is an
entire game built on chicken puns this
entire game does your family even listen
to you anymore no when you sit there
they've disowned me my dog doesn't even
listen to me anymore i just turned a
turret into a chicken yes because in
this game everything can be yeah i know
applied chicken technology i don't know
if you're grasping it here
what is something that you do on a daily
basis oh i can't say it on there
okay that's applied chicken technologies
brushing your teeth you probably didn't
realize you brushed your teeth with
chicken
paint that is what happens when you run
over your own special weapon partner hey
who just hit me with a missile i did oh
really
all right where are you go team so i'm
going to put that in a turret so i can
chicken all right i see how this is come
here
eat it
all right i think it may be time for the
special weapon attack i think it may be
that time hey
come on i got it i got a button
all right all right okay trophy
i'm gonna win this one i swear to god
yeah we got we gotta win this no we are
not oh yeah we're on the same team i
forgot yep i have enough i haven't not
don't worry about that all we have to do
is just punch them in the face and we
will win hey hey yes that is a
legitimate chicken coop approved
strategy for winning gloucester clark so
like at this point we kind of like run
out of treasure chests around so the
only now
all right here we go
oh i must hurry to the chicken in the
immortal words
bits what is what
units is that chickens
yeah i mean everything is chickens the
international currency of chicken okay
that's fair yeah that sounds good do one
more all right one more here we go
all right feel like i think you like
figured it out at this point danny
lots of things can get turned into
chickens everything can get turned into
chicken we are going to tar and feather
them that's how hard this is going to
get chicken eyes
come here
no
all right
you can't turn the chickens in the
chicken oh well that's going pretty
metal oh you're going in the chicken no
you disappear
oh there we go
yes that was hedging i was like some tom
brady actually
picked it out of your hands nice what
that's not what tom brady the opposite
of tom brady
she was being tom brady there we go and
who who in this scenario is i don't
understand stop writing
i intercepted it right you got it okay
there's nothing more fun than stealing
chicken from someone else your metaphor
situation could use a little work that's
why i keep putting
chicken breaks nice
come here
nope somebody ah all right
oh we only got 20 seconds drop that
chick here we go come on now now an
approved tactic you can use put a mine
on top of the chicken eiser
it is perfectly legal in this game oh
what the you got
just devolved into infighting you know
it's just
just a sad state of affairs over there
nice you give it up here greta that was
pretty awesome
that was pretty good
victories
when can people play this fluster clock
of a video game fluster cluck october
21st on the ps4 that's pretty close yeah
that's really really close
your studio is weird you were telling me
beforehand how you guys were like
instrumental in the creation of the dvd
we did a bunch of crazy stuff yeah we
really did we actually helped we helped
dvds we have heard of those
kind of important stuff right yeah we
did some pretty crazy stuff i mean we
actually helped pioneer part of the dvd
format we did a bunch of crazy stuff
we're game studio right now focused on
porting games to playstation bringing
our own ips to playstation but we've
done a bunch of stuff they made
playstation home stuff yeah yeah yeah
isn't that good it's home shutting down
soon yeah yeah the announcement went out
about that you know but you guys gonna
have like a last hurrah in there like a
nice chicken dinner
playstation home
chicken suits well yeah yeah i'm not
afraid to put on some feathers yeah fine
there you go i'm just saying massive
geeks right there that actually yeah we
should we should just every single one
of us with the headdress yeah because
underneath these lights the last you
know just some downy fluff yeah you need
on top of it yeah yeah it's almost
winter it's an adhesive it's welcome to
the lobby
sure why not stick with the classics
all right evil within trailers up next
but jason greta thank you so much for
coming in thanks for showing us
for everyone who's been watching the
lobby if you guys like
you guys like this game you want to play
this game go to our facebook page
fluster cluck game
answer this question what is the icon
that you get when you're camping you saw
it when these guys were playing because
he's a camper chicken spurious claims
we're going to select 10 people who
answered that question select randomly
and they're going to get a free copy of
fluster class sweet yeah not immediately
though
you've got to answer by 9 a.m tomorrow
nine a.m tomorrow okay yeah and what
like like our facebook page all right
social media yeah happening right here
in the lobby and we'll be back in a
second we've got a shadows mordor to end
the show but next up is forza
motorsport no horizon no
it's almost what it's called needs
chicken evil within
foreign
the evil within the disturbing new
experience from the father of survival
horror shinji makami takes us into the
twisted world of detective sebastian
castianos as he unravels the horrific
details of who or what is terrorizing
crimson city
what the hell
weapons and ammunition are a luxury
one you cannot always depend on when
confronting the haunted
out of ammo
not having them at your disposal can
turn what should have been a quick kill
into a run for your life
staying hidden in the shadows may save
your life and give you the upper hand
when ammo is running low
the evil within is a living nightmare of
sinister creatures
unforgiving environments and lethal
traps meant to capture meme and kill
you'll need to be creative and figure
out how to turn obstacles into assets
while sometimes your enemies may appear
to be dead
it's best to make absolutely sure
throughout the world there are points
where sebastian can access a safe haven
known as the asylum
you're always welcome here it is in this
mysterious place that he can upgrade his
weapons abilities and inventory these
upgrades will help you with your
survival without them you're as good as
dead
to solve the mysteries of a city where
everything has gone wrong
you'll need to survive first and
foremost
but learning the tools of the trade
will only help your chances because
you'll need more than bullets
if you're going to make it out alive
the evil within chris you have any
interest in playing that video game i
don't danny know dude no
you know this about me scary games like
games that are trying to like mess with
you with weird crap
no i don't like it i feel like i play
like resident evil 4 i really like that
one but that unnerved me and resident
evil like the original one with fixed
camera angles forget it it took me
months to get through yeah that stuff
messes with my brain i don't dream right
after that happens i don't sleep well no
thank you what about alien isolation
then because that's i would give it a
shot it's creepy yeah it's not the
different type of heart yeah but like so
like i would try alien isolation but
like dead space
yeah and uh
it's too good yeah at freaking people
out
and i'm very susceptible to that yeah
we're talking about horror games we've
got car games to talk about andy bauman
all right that sounds good andy baman's
here and we're gonna play uh forza
horizon motorsports too
right now danny i went into the
motorsports menu horizon there's no
motorsports forza horizon 2. nailed it
look at this action you guys i can set
the tire pressure oh man hold on where
do you think i should go 2.2 2.2 no no
ah can you mess with your diff yeah hold
on we'll get to the diff okay okay i
really want a lot of that much pressure
in the future i told you 2.2 and then
that much said here okay apply
all right let's go to the diff okay diff
it up what is the diff just at the back
give me the diff all right
you sound like it launches what
it's locked forget
you're a big fan of uh the photo the
forza motorsports series yeah
specifically four and five yes uh but
horizon has you're also very talented
you kind of dared
so we're playing on shawn's account
uh who is not here today so i took his
place indeed before it's a guy he has
reviewed the game on gamespot.com that
is
actually inaccurate this is not true
this is it
no no it wasn't him either because he
was too close he's too close to that he
previewed it a whole bunch yeah so now
i'm sucking i don't know all right so
forza horizon 2
is takes everything that's great about
forza was the tuning the amount of cars
you can drive the physics system the the
telemetry of of the driving and brings
it into an open world basically like
that do you see a commercial where the
cars were going on the track and they
were like stuck in the in the track
divot i should probably keep my hands on
the wheels your hands
and then they break away from the track
and then they're they're all having fun
and like
whenever i saw sean playing this he
seemed to just be driving through
forests yeah at breakneck speed yeah
that's actually like let me make the
description of this game a lot easier
for you andy
forza horizon 2 is the sequel to forza
horizon yeah but you know
uh but it's in europe so instead of road
tripping across the united states to go
to festivals and listen to music and
whatnot yeah yeah yeah colorado um which
is you're in like italy and france yeah
this doesn't look like ireland
no this looks like the nice part of
you're just [ __ ] killing people on
the road oh dude those you know
rub painting is wait rubbing is racing
rubbing it
i'm staying on the road like a good
forza driver sure none of those horizon
malarkey these are all driver tires as
well right some of them a lot of these
are just cars that get in your way like
they're just yeah so these these are
just ai cars but then you will anytime
you see a name i don't think we're
hooked up to an online session so
they're going to be all drivatars okay
uh yeah the drivatar stuff that forza
introduced in motorsport 5
is here and still pretty good from the
reports driving tires are actually
really good uh they make the driving
really unpredictable everybody kind of
just runs into each other yeah in four
to five so i imagine it's kind of like
that in this game i loved how they had
personality because
apparently i don't know why because i
actually thought i was quite a decent
driver in forza but apparently my driver
tower was an absolute jerk but i've seen
your drivers
four to five yeah yeah but that's cool
it's cool that like
you would see somebody's name and be
like oh no like
yeah
yeah it adds a little more personality
to the whole racing experience so even
if it is fake robo personality that they
made up based on your data i sure wish i
knew what to do in this game chris
waters why don't you tell me well andy
there
there are quests and side quests you can
go on to earn new loot and level up
chris tell me about barnes how do we
also there are some places on the map
that you go and search for a barn and
it's basically just you driving around
being like hey is there a barn here and
not finding a barn and then your live
stream ends on a real low note oh so
you've been here before when you go to
the bar that was just a random example
not specific at all what does the chat
have any specific uh let's take a look
at the map room you know whatever
questions hold on i can't pause when i'm
driving yeah
let's look at the world map here france
so here you are in france
look it's nice it's pretty nice in
france it is nice france is nice uh and
you look around like if you head to the
east then you're into like italy area
eat that's soggy waffle oh the horizon
festival
the horizon so you go to these festivals
that have different car events but then
you've got also these like bucket list
chat like i think you can fast travel to
horizon points because also these like
all those little green
icons are bucket list challenges where
you go and do a very specific thing with
a very specific car
uh there's other stuff that's sort of
like impromptu races uh inside of this
montelino like inside this big opaque
circle
is the barn hunt
that shawn and i tried at the end of the
live stream but were unsuccessful at
finding that barn can you like pick an
off-road race there can i go to duck
tour into this lake
you know those big trucks that go yeah
there's a duck tour boat in forza
horizon they have they have 200 cars why
not a duck trying to find an off-road
race okay maybe like closer to where you
actually orange one there oh really oh
can i just fast travel yeah just click
on one yeah just click if you look near
near yourself
then you can you know just drive a race
nope that's a driver's heart it's vent
hanging out those are like speed zones
so if you kept going if you kept going
at high speed currently you would go
through that speed zone it's kind of
like a leave your stamp and then your
buddies see your like uh your all right
let's go to this
oh there's a car there's an orange one
over there if you want to off road
there's one that's literally in the
middle of a giant empty
forest is it right there see that
it's new too do it bucket list
all right you're never gonna make it
there try to travel to the horizon
festival okay down here yeah okay
where's hx press x
zero credits
you guys look at this now we get to sit
in traffic for a while we also get to
see the scenery it's pretty dry look at
this coastline you ever been to the
european coast of the mediterrane so
i'll share with you guys yeah
why i like playing sports is it because
you please do you kind of accidentally
bought a subaru two weeks ago that
that's probably a um
you bought a car by accident so you
should set your waypoint so you know
where you're going i bought a baller wrx
you did have and they had it requires
remorse well a little bit but that's
your waypoint it's got one of those
really retardedly loud sorry that's a
bad word on the map it's fine mufflers
and so it's awesome it's got a really
loud muffler yeah okay which you know
that's just not my personality but
it is now there's an app left top left
right here perfect get there
get there andy i did i am let's go back
all right so anyway turn around
instantly turn around again i would say
that's a symptom of being into forza
because as brian really as brian ekberg
puts it oh yeah gamespot i love that
remember brian eckberg
turned out developer of fort superior
the community side of things and he his
quote when we went and filmed this huge
like thing about forza 5 was we want to
turn game lovers into car lovers and car
lovers into game lovers and as hokey as
that sounds
forza totally did that that's how it
happened to you yeah and
uh
when i'm playing this game it's it
literally is like being in the moment in
a way that no other game
really gets you it kind of reminds me of
like playing games like skate
where you're just kind of ambling
around you're like just picking up
getting distracted and like exploring
and stuff like that
oh yeah and like i don't i think we're
not playing with all the
i guess you could say the modes of like
how hard it is to play like you turn on
the simulation settings too you know no
traction control assist no
anti-lock brake assist no automatic
crashes actually aren't just cosmetic
damage they cause bodies oh yeah
it's actually challenging to play that
way it's not good for the stream
probably but like
you really learn how to feather the
triggers and feather the the control
sticks and like listen to the car for
feedback basically you know where you're
gonna lose traction
that drivetar is having trouble i bet i
bet the europeans are really angry at
all these
folks just turn it up and drive driving
cars all around yeah it's a real
detriment to the local agricultural
scene not to mention the
wildlife just being terrorized
yeah so that's why i love forza because
you really lose yourself in the game
more than you do with like another
arcade type racer because those
just don't have the same
feeling
yeah cause i was yeah it was kind of a
misnomer when the first one came out
that i always i kind of thought oh it's
the arcade version of
forza and you know maybe to a certain
extent in terms of like the game modes
and stuff but like
uh yeah the driving the handling all
that stuff is still yeah like it retains
all that stuff yeah the the telemetry is
modeled in such a way that it's just
it's so
thrilling to drive i don't know like
compared to the crew for example like
yeah
all right great job andy yeah live
streams you can get there yeah there's
like a ton of rocks just drive around
them how do i i'm close enough can i
just drive it into this ancient come on
friggin building
which like
now has got all your dirty
nissan or whatever this is i think it's
a pujo here we go there you go or
reynold no it's a rental renault renault
renault these aren't american cars i
don't know how to pronounce them ford
rally atlanta delta s4 through a forest
at night i feel like i've seen this one
a million times they put it in the uh
the preview coverage is that on your
bucket list
i have like have a threesome on mine but
in a
foreign at night in a forest well that
is not the button for change views
anymore
all right hey chris how do i change
views overwhelmed why that's how you do
it no that's how you rewind it looks
pretty as well
shoulder click the stick this is okay is
this where you meet the slender man oh
there it is yeah dude
guys you want to go on a road trip
i'm a really good driver guys trust me i
do this all the time it's fun sparks
andy you've had too much to drink yes
they were bud lights it's fine there's
barely any alcohol in those they're utah
beer there's only three people just one
try my drink like 340s and did this and
it was fun
this is the worst
you've ever seen someone drive you got
it
keep it up yeah don't worry about come
on guys take this this is a fresh fresh
shot hold on you got it you got it
all right here we go all right let's go
for it you have to dodge all the farmers
banging that you see
watch out for the trees whoa whoa
that was unavoidable
you saw it that tree came out of it just
jumped up man
these fast growing trees i don't know
what these gmo crops they're growing in
europe now monsanto trees
[ __ ] instagram trees whoa whoa all
right
oh is that the horizon festival over
there because it's sure is that a river
you're definitely gonna make it in one
minute hold on let me turn on the turbo
charger
oh no try again
well now that i know where the trees are
we'll have it better
you're going to give it another try try
again yeah
hold on we have to i don't really
believe in you i usually tell people i
believe in them to like bolster her
confidence
and not feel confident i just didn't
have a tight enough grip on the
controller okay i feel it helps you
gotta wipe your sword yeah and you got
really grippy you could hit the gas at
the start of the race also i like and
then you make this
for two seconds for no reason i wasn't
ready yet all right
it's gonna pay off
jesus christ get in the zone oh i'm
drifting get in the zone tokyo drift
your way down this french hillside
and avoid these crazy monsanto trees oh
it's very standard the forest is very
thick right now oh man
that means slenderman's getting close
yeah the screen gets old yeah it's
screen gets all cracked
i hope they didn't want this car back in
one piece oh
this is why you don't let me drive your
own car like noted
this is like getting to my parents house
though really so i shouldn't be good at
this
bolting through the woods yeah is your
dad slenderman
you have to like hit a ramp at the exit
of the forest to leap a canyon
don't worry dude did you see how clean
that is that was nice that was really
good come on you're gonna eat something
so hard right now i can tell
i think it actually might be better if
you just stay on the road
it says race through the forest at night
why would it tell me don't go off book
nine seconds impossible
yeah these are pretty hard actually i
saw
it's because it's like two kilometers
away
yeah they are very hard also there's
wood on this tree that you're about to
hit is very hard all right well that was
fun let's do another one cool yeah let's
try something else
so yeah you just kind of like race
around you listen to some radio stations
you get get into the groove
maybe you do a race of one kind or
another it's just kind of like a little
um i feel like these try to go for a
different kind of immersion that you
when you were talking about that earlier
were you speaking about your experience
with forza 5's 45 yeah
definitely definitely did you play
horizon much
a lot of there was a lot of love for
horizon it was pretty i couldn't see why
because like dude you go around those
tracks so much don't do a super hot
hatch we did that on the other live
stream you're just burning shawn's
credits to fast travel sorry sure uh you
just
you play those same tracks over and over
right like they're fun though like super
stone you could you want to go to the
right you know nurburgring now is back
in four to five which is great and uh
now they have long beach those are fun
but it's like the same tradition over
and over road america
yeah
like i'm so good at the corkscrew like
there's actually not that many tracks in
there's not at all and you're just quite
shocked yeah you start just playing them
over and then so to have this open world
to just be able to drive in like a bunch
of new places
totally made up europe town
it's nice though so it's not totally
made up i mean it's inspired by the real
by true events
yeah well let's find it
much like find one more new that's it it
says new right there four four right no
i think we did that on the live stream
oh why'd you say it says new though sure
then we didn't do it all right what
about this one
oh that's the one you did yeah you do
that yeah it's close street race
let's see your street racer skills
race on the street
do you normally do the cockpit cam is
this your jam yeah i like the car
right here yeah just bang her right
what's up with his hands his hands are
weird oh they don't know how to animate
hands at turn 10. yeah all right if you
are a good hand animator you should hit
up brian ekberg there might be like uh
cc me though cause
you want to get that
you want to get the referee
yeah
that definitely exists that's how
referral bonuses work yeah just anybody
at any time yeah yo they should make
obama president
give me that referral that referral
bonus no they line those up way in
advance that's big money
jesse jackson
all right annie try not to suck so bad
this fort street race cool can i can i
no it's my car no oh wait change your
car i don't know whatever you're in a
hot hatch man there are people in the
chat who i'm sure just waiting for
shadows and more of the shadows do a
hatchimal yeah that game's boss yeah
we're not talking about that now
we can we're hyping it up though
we have a review for that game up yeah
yeah because
we're good at our jobs
we sure are
but you're not that good at driving come
on man they're all in front of you look
make a power move all right it's not
until like the last second where you
want to be in first giggle who's in
front of you what is this mario kart oh
you're going to get a better item
tower's downfall though is that they all
kind of mess the corners up although
it's better it was better than the ai
because in ports before the ai would
just go really slow oh really what to
compensate i don't know yeah they just
weren't as cool yo j fizz 99 do you
reckon he was born in 99 how galling
would it be if you were beaten by a 15
year old
drivatar
two year olds are good at video games
that's true yeah that would not actually
be that surprising their neural
receptors are
turbo boosting they're mlg yeah they've
got like the fast reasons yeah they're
all they're they're just no scoping you
right now if i do lose it's probably
because i put the tire pressure on my
front tire
too much i wouldn't let you change the
door that was a really bad block
that was really bad advice that i gave
you in horizon
there's weather rain there's rain that
rain looks pretty damn good actually
yeah
they got like
rendering on the rain
yeah they sprinkle some rendering on
that yeah
render man if only the
when is the review going up
well kevin when's the review going
kevin's got it in forza horizon
when's the review going on
oh come on it's a long story apparently
they're gonna have a street race at
least close it down no
that's how they do it in europe
it's that's why they call it zuropa
everyone that's what everyone calls that
whole continent yeah really yeah yeah i
haven't called it europe in years
i only called it europe over here so you
guys know what i'm talking about yeah
when he moved to frisco he just started
calling you zuropa
you guys are just clowns
yeah listen man someone's got to provide
the comedic relief
all right
give me an occupation
o'clock guys get in we're going for a
race drive
85 andy you can do it you know what the
problem 4 out of 12. the muffler on this
car is too quiet
you're a big muffler man you want a
black you want if it's not black black
blatant yeah yeah your race is flat
that's how we call them andy the muff
lover bowman
yeah just like the big muffler hi mom i
hope not watching right now oh hi mom
it's your birthday today happy birthday
mom it's your birthday your mom's
birthday it's not my birthday it's my
mom hey i got sean 12 points you should
at least be a little bit happy andy
bowman congratulations
you were only beaten by video burritos
wow we said like every other car besides
an astra yeah is that a european car
opelastra yeah yeah they're they make
them in zurich i only drive superheroes
sorry what's opal called is it vauxhall
it's called outside of ireland
yeah i'll tell you what though driving
that wrx is the best driving it's so fun
in real life and he's talking about his
real car right now he's clever so fun
can you okay but you you shut it down
you did go back to the shop because they
sold it to like a crack in the exhaust
and you wanted to get the muffler taken
out because it was too obnoxious yeah
but then you didn't i haven't yet so
what i know you live in oakland you need
to put a whistler in there
i set off someone's car alarm with the
muffler
you're that guy you're that guy in the
neighborhood it's so fun to drive it's
like incredible does that mean that you
can't come home i can do forza horizon
in real life i can just go off-road you
know stop me yeah okay sometimes you
have to go off-road you do yeah you're
going to you're going to sound oakland
you need to you need to get out of there
gtfo yeah yeah i just
go away that's how you guys use gtfo in
cities on roads yeah okay there's no
fields i need heaven for the horizon
it's uh i can't wait to actually force
the horizon it's two two it's good but
it's not as good as owning it's one to
me it's new to me it's new to everybody
i assume national geographic andy thank
you very much going on shadows of mordor
sorry shadow one shadow that's the
sequel also it's middle earth shadow
i'm going to be pedantic about that
title all segment long it's going to be
awesome lowercase e but a hyphen
middle earth shadow of mordor coming up
next after we take a quick look at the
trailer for its season pass
there will be more battles charlie
we must prepare
get the season pass to unlock an
exclusive mission to destroy the
guardians of the flaming eye and battle
sauron's elite legions to earn epic
runes
test your skills in four challenged
modes gain experience and runes and
compare your victories with friends on
the online leaderboards season pass
owners unlocked every challenge mode
instantly for a head start in their
domination of mordor
time to go hunting
gain new skills and unique epic rooms as
you hunt and tame legendary monsters of
mordor in these all-new story missions
my powers return
play as keller brim great belvin king of
the second age and wheel the ring of
power to face the dark lord sauron
himself
i like it
middle earth shadow of mordor hordor
there's a there's a conflict raging in
our office danny what is it and it is
over what the proper pronunciation of
mordor is
the proper stupid pronunciation of
mordor i should say i prefer mort dolph
yeah i like that the hugo weaving from
lord of the rings but you go in for the
game of thrones represent yeah mordor
kevin as the official reviewer for
middle earth shadow mordor what do you
go for see i always thought it was like
gold frankincense and
mordor so i'm just like it's
well regardless that's what jesus got
that one sounds
he did he got frankincense he got
frankenstein and a copy of uh middle
earth shadow mortar which was quite
golden because the ps4 wasn't invented
until 2014 years later it was mostly the
shiny disc that really gave it to you he
got excited about it's like a little
diorama yeah yeah just because you're
born in a manger doesn't mean you can't
have a diorama manger i'm thinking of uh
you're thinking of manager a mobile i'm
thinking of a mobile yo this game is
pretty good apparently yeah yeah it's
quite good quite quite good it looks
pretty as hell and the first thing i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna do a leap of faith
um
off of the uh off of the tower so you
were in the our review on gamespot.com
uh you were pretty quick to draw
comparisons to assassinino well it's
kind of impossible not to
but good comparisons right oh yeah yeah
i mean i love assassin's creed it's
pretty well established
all right we're playing this on the ps4
as well it's just so people yeah uh one
of them yeah what did you make this head
into and this is that is um i use it for
butternut squash soup later yeah uh
tangy this is after the game is finished
so this is in the the just the open
world um all of the side stuff there's
no story stuff left for me so now it's
just tooling around and doing whatever i
want is that why it's vaguely sunny
because you made the sunshine on mordor
i i don't think that's really how it
this is not what it is
this is not actually mordor this is the
other the other area that i'm not going
to mention because i'm going to get
like the fighting combat action the how
the mission stuff works it's super great
so it does obviously take a hang on it's
so hard to talk and play at the same
time sometimes
so it does take its cues from assassin's
creed clearly but the combat is probably
is is more batman arkham
and it's more difficult than both those
games the combat situations like
into trouble let's see if i can go find
a way to get into find some trouble
that's just
like once you start picking a fight with
orcs especially if there's a captain
around
uh the captains are sort of these you
know
there's this whole nemesis system that
you know you fight these marquee
captains and learn sort of uh
information about them so that you know
how to better kill them and then you
sort of move up the ranks that's sort of
how you progress to try to to start some
[ __ ] but uh
they like
if you get into a battle and like two
captains are in there and then their
whole bunch of their buddies are there
too you can get overwhelmed really
easily and just get worked yeah i've
gotten worked a lot in my first few
hours of playing this game because i
don't run away because i'm like haha
bring it on everybody i'll kill you oh
god no and you have to run especially if
they if they like ring their bell
um
you can be screwed big time if that
happens like you'll go from having maybe
20 dudes around you and suddenly you'll
have maybe 60
um and suddenly you're like i can't do
this yeah
um one of the most interesting things
i've seen in its preview coverage i
haven't touched this yet at all um
is the whole
the nemesis system stuff but the the
fact that like if you
if you die because of your character's
sort of situation he is revived or
whatever because of christ
here's what i was hoping to do is be
able to do this so i'm gonna brand him
and that means i basically convert him
to my cause okay kara gore you're in the
way thank you
it listened
i did what does this do
so i'm gonna i'm gonna convert him to my
cause over and over and over again so
now he'll just simply fight for for me
but i can still use him for other stuff
like i can
i'll dominate him now
and this is one of the creepiest things
my one of my favorite things in the game
is so you're playing um basically a a a
ranger basically a dead ranger yeah for
all intents and purposes and a wraith
um that are combined into one body
essentially when you do that you're
using the wraith skills to uh
to uh learn about the snaps
so so here we go into the nemesis system
so i've i've gone ahead and not only
have i converted him to my cause but now
i've gone into his brain okay and and
now i can do a few things so you see the
entire
hierarchy of orcs here now i can dismiss
him now now this is by the way you don't
get a lot of this stuff until much later
in the game so don't be sad when you
first when you first start playing you
have access to some of these skills but
now i can dismiss him and
to fight he can fight for my cause then
and spread the fear
or i can just kill him i think i'm just
gonna dismiss him because now he'll
fight for me
i'm to what end well to what end what
what's gonna happen then i'll i'll go
back in to
the army so what will happen then is
like eventually you want to uh
convert all of the warchiefs to your
cause okay and the the best way of doing
that is to start at the bottom of the
hierarchy convert some of these guys to
your cause and then what will happen is
as they start growing up the ranks
eventually they'll earn the the warchief
status and then you'll have a war chief
in place it's all very political
machinations kind of stuff but uh it's
kind of easiest to start from the ground
up i mean it's really hard to just go
after a warchief from a conceptual level
that sounds absolutely brilliant and it
really does work out the way it sounds
um the first half of the game so it's
basically sort of split into two acts
the first half you know you do a lot of
that stuff but it's
it's not as involved as the second half
when you really start to get into some
of that cool stuff and one of my
favorite things is just to go into a
camp and then start converting everybody
and then i can call out the warchief and
suddenly i'll have like a war going on
um between between different dudes
between your mind slaves and the other
orcs so you have stuff like that when
you do that like if if i convert
one dude if i take over his mind and
then he and then he then gets an
opportunity to like fight another guy
that i haven't taken over i can join in
on the on the uh on the fight are you
gonna do something like that right now
cool um and does that stuff get like
boring at any stage because it sounds
like
so fascinating like as you like a couple
of hours in does it become like played
out at all or is it not really but i i
think with i mean not for me anyway yeah
but i think with something like this it
sort of comes down to how much you love
the fundamentals and i think the
fundamentals are really strong
especially if you do and i hate to keep
drawing the comparison but it's a really
easy one to make which is the assassin's
creed comparison if you do like the
structure of assassin's creed but just
wished it had for example better combat
and was more challenging and things like
that then i think you're going to get a
real a real kick out of this and it
doesn't really get old for me in part
because i like the feel i'm i'm still
doing that kind of creedy thing going up
the cliffs and whatnot so you're sorry
no just curious for you kevin coming
into this you're obviously a huge fan of
the assassin's creed franchise uh how do
you feel about the lord of the rings i
love the lord of the rings i'm not one
of the so i i know all the books and
i've watched all the movies and i've
played so so many lord of the rings
games it's not even funny
but on the other hand i'm not one of
those guys i'm not like the comic book
guy of the lord of the rings universe or
anything it's not like i'm i'm so
involved that i understand all of the uh
the ins and outs of the universe there
are a lot of a lot of people that are
much better at knowing that stuff than
me but you don't need to have that much
like knowledge no and in the end i think
the story in this game is pretty
disappointing all things considered um
it's it's not bad you shoot the bees
yeah i'm gonna shoot the bees oh god not
the base so this terrorizes
and then why do they even let the bees
live there
these guys are terrible i think they're
actually called mordor flies they're not
technically bees but come on if you're
not calling them bees
bees i forget what their name is
so here is let's see
there we go this is your assassin's
vision
so he's going to introduce himself to me
because he's a i think he's a captain
okay so i'm going to just wait for him
to do that i think
i don't think no he's not never mind so
yeah when they do that um if you've had
like priors with them oh god damn it uh
they are like if you if you
lost to them in the past they'll say
like i thought you were dead and yeah
it's so cool if you come across a dude
and uh oh execution i just kind of like
doing that so she like doing that look
at that it's sick as hell
if you come across a dude that you've
already
that's beaten you before so when you die
you you go back to one of those towers
like when i first started okay
um and then you can go back and try to
go after the guy again so now i've
converted him in in the course so he'll
just go out he'll he'll just kind of
hang i'll just go home
so anyway sorry about that i i get
i'm so use your use your like ratho
vision and see which guy you want to go
after right yeah i'm gonna go find a
supporter well he's the i gotta grab the
supporter he's the guy that's marked in
yellow
what do you mean supporter
so he's supporting one of the chiefs and
in order to get to the chiefs i grab i i
need to get to the supporters sometimes
to draw out like a warchief you have to
uh you have to sort of uh you have to do
certain things sometimes it just means
uh
killing supporters
oh here's a fun thing i can do
whoa all right
hacks
i'm sorry that i'm not very good at
talking and playing at the same time
it just so happens that this is a game
you could probably watch being played
for quite a while yep it's actually
entertaining i love that fireplace back
there it's just like yeah a maw like
what do you even what is the
practicality of having those oh
by the way you just saw
a sort of splinter silver vision
where it shows you the little ghost of
where you just were that tells you that
they know yeah someone is arguing and
that's the last place so it's it seems
like there's a lot of variety in terms
of how to kill people i remember seeing
with that nemesis murder that random
dude for that was cold as ice i like
that you can like get them in the leg
and then trap them there can you throw
them off the cliff grab them and throw
them off
just
nice
do it to this guy too
okay
just chuck them off the bridge come on
come on it's more fun to do
okay i'm not gonna be able to do this
any longer and the the supporter oh oh
sorry kevin
are you decaying hostage i need to keep
them hostage that's all right
it was much more fun to just throw these
dies off the uh through these guys
it reminds me like keep me here saints
row two we sat around for a whole
afternoon just grabbing pedestrians and
chucking them over off of a bridge into
the water so their heads would clang
against the metal guard rail
there seems to be a lot of um variety in
terms of when you're entering these
places like can you go on in august
blazing and also do like the stealth
stuff can you get in there and like
assassin's creed one style kill
that one warlord sometimes you you
absolutely can right now i'm gonna run
because i'm probably gonna get my ass
yeah there were a lot of dudes there
that was a good run situ like runaway
situation so but i saw the meat there it
is
al oh and the beast falls and the bees
oh is there bees i didn't see the bees
there are but yeah there's the bees okay
get the bees get the bees get the bees
oh god damn it you're like she's just
wrong
oh there's more bees there's some bees
on parade
now i'm out of elf shot so look at that
all of those
all of those red uh triangles that were
following you are now like running away
and crapping themselves in fear oh yeah
they're all they all spread out all over
the place yeah and that's super helpful
again you know it's funny because in
assassin's creed you know how
you know there's so many ways of doing
stuff but you're never actually given a
reason to do all those things you can go
through the entire game never doing all
sorts of [ __ ] like using all your little
gadgets
you know here you actually need that
stuff because the game's actually pretty
challenging and so i find myself
sneaking around and this has an actual
sneak button look at this gang of
hooligans i feel like this game kind of
in a way crept out of nowhere like we we
covered a lot of e3 and we had like
we've had sort of a lot of access to it
especially all that nemesis stuff but
it's it kind of ended up being like a
you know it's a it's a
a filament book
you know licensed game that is
better than assassin's creed iv like
it's is this like the best version of an
assassin i don't know if i would say it
is as good as assassin's creed iv i
think um i would probably say ultimately
i think assassin's creed four is better
but i didn't really like four so maybe
that's just me well it sort of depends
too like i think assassin's creed has
had a lot longer right to like build up
story and to do interesting things and
uh i think that's where this game kind
of loses it a little bit is in the story
and also in the sort of the diversity of
the environments and the things that
you're doing i think assassin's creed
does a better job how big is the map
because you looked at something earlier
but i think that was just this so here's
this you get two maps of approximately
this size okay
so here's um
oh i'm trying to remember i don't
remember how to get to the other map or
two
maybe
no no that's all right it's fine but
there's there's there's another there
are two maps of basically the same
system
does it feel small or restricted just
cross your eyes and you'll see them well
only only in the sense that a lot of the
times the areas start to really look the
same okay um but
i never felt restricted at all it always
felt like there were places to go and
things to do there grab that guy he's
the intel yeah i know that's why i'm not
going to kill him don't murder him but
i'm going to try to murder the other
dudes first so but so in that respect
like it's not it doesn't remind you of
something like like any of the
assassin's creeds in terms of having
this kind of quite grand playground to
to
explore yeah ooh it's
does it does it feel like more of an
action game like or maybe like arkham
city or something
it does have a little bit more of that
uh
sorry it's i'm so bad it's talking at
the same time
um but it does have a little bit more of
that
go from place to place and sort of that
this is just the kind of thing you do is
you chase the waypoints and do the
things they say there and then once you
clear that one up you go on to the next
i feel like assassin's creed is maybe a
little bit more
um
the pacing is a little bit less
rhythmic yeah in that sense it gives you
a lot of other stuff to do but again
it's had so long to do that to put in
ship combat and to do this and to do
that so now like for example i know that
this guy is a bodyguard for this
warchief so it would actually do me good
to
to go after this guy
but i already know him
but you can gain intel on his strengths
and weaknesses yes you can do that
there's like two tiers of of intel it's
knowing who they are and where they are
and then the second tier is all their
attributes their strengths and
weaknesses right which comes in very
handy to know as i found out when here i
am hopping on a carragher i'm like this
dude had killed me once and i was like
oh i'm gonna get you so i got on and i
raced up on him his back was turned i
was gonna bite his head off and he just
like casually turns and stabs the crap
out of the category and then murders me
because he's like a monster a monster
killer and can't be killed by monsters
and like can destroy them super easily
that sounds like damn it like it really
seems like this game is like not so you
know go completely crazy but like i i
can't remember a game that's done
something like this before in terms of
like the researching that that's the
stuff that strikes me is the the getting
the intel about your your targets uh
sort of it was certainly impactful in
that moment uh for me
and then also like you were saying about
the sort of the moving up the ladders
like the machinations of i'm gonna set
this guy against this guy or i should
really target this dude to get
information about this other guy and
like working your way up to the bosses
so that the bosses feel
like bosses i guess like once you get
there kevin does it feel like
man i've worked hard to get here like it
is on like this is going to be a i'm
going to take this dude down and it's
going to be really satisfying it really
does and it's funny because when i first
heard about a lot of this stuff my worry
was oh it's all going to be kind of
meaningless it's going to be window
dressing that doesn't really have an
impact it'll just be there to be there
you know what i mean and the fact that
it wasn't that is what amazed me the
most about well how many game systems
have we heard talked about big and then
they just don't turn out yeah especially
when you hear that with assassin's creed
a lot and i again i hate using that it's
just such an easy comparison to go to
but you hear that a lot it's like oh
well this time that you know the you
know we're making this more meaningful
or stealth more meaningful this game
actually did it
and it found a good way to do it and it
knew that the best way to do that was
just to to make it challenging
and when you make things challenging
then you give the other the other
elements a reason to exist like chris
you're it sounds really cool that whole
like character bit where like if you had
known that information he would have
definitely would have not done that yeah
but then like the whole thing where
in boss fights in most games you you
attempt to do it and if you don't do it
you just reload you do it again whereas
in this one if you lose to these guys
they actually get more powerful
yeah they get more powerful they might
like move to a different spot they might
be surrounded they might it might be a
different location with different
entourage around them or different
environment environmental elements
around them and so
yeah like it does feel like you have to
adapt you know it's not just like
hitting your head against the wall until
you determine like all right yeah i'm
just gonna hit it a few more times and
then i'll get it because that probably
makes those boss encounters then feel
like way more significant than most they
really do especially because they they
introduce
the the uh the captain and the war chief
every time with a great big i'm gonna
get you and blah blah blah and it's like
whoa the drama is almost too much for me
well you were telling me that what like
with some guys they'll like the orcs
will chant their name
the war chiefs when it when the warchief
comes out you draw the warchief out um
what happens is in the soundtrack um
it's like let's say the guy's name is
hork and they're like that's one of the
early guys is hork so they'll go like
pork pork
pork pork and it's really cool when they
do that because it's like wow they
really you know this is this is
something this fight's meaningful yeah
and you know the name because you've
been targeting that dude like the
previous hour or however long it's taken
you but a lot of the other a lot of the
other dudes it just ends up being you
know i think some of the names are just
procedurally generated okay
sorry i just couldn't help myself i mean
there's also like a pool you know like
i've seen a few
not in my game but in like a couple
different games there's different uh
proc like prak this guy pr ak but he's
different things he's like the raven
slayer or you know the biter i don't
know like baselayer is a bit crap in
there yeah
ravens okay to the bird the bird hunter
they do a really good job of making sure
they set up the orcs
in a way
where you understand that they're not
necessarily just one giant you know hive
mind they're not like all sauron's
you know eyes and ears quite yet they
have minds of their own and they they
clash and
you know there's there's no sense of
somebody asked me this on twitter and i
i might as well mention there's no sense
of like
this guy you know this these peop these
guys believe in this and these guys
believe in this it's not
well
it's political but it's self-serving in
that sense it's like they're all out for
themselves but they know something big
is going down in mordor and also like
the men really aren't around so it's
kind of a good place to be
be a basically like a pirate these guys
are kind of pirates they they feel like
that yeah they really do because there's
like a land outside of law you know of
the just another way in which this is
like assassin's creed four
pirates i never even thought of the
pirate connection but they you know they
are they're the the orc are pretty gruff
so i like it i i this yeah everything
i've heard about this and like people
chatting around the office stuff this
game sounds like an absolute like
wonderful little pleasant surprise
oh yeah i'm looking forward to i wasn't
expecting it to be as good as it was i
mean not that i really expected i mean
when i i play so many games now that
it's hard to go into any game with with
any
expectation per se
um but you know i think this would truly
classify as sort of an out of nowhere
hit yeah you know and
i mean it's lord of the rings people are
going to buy lord of the rings stuff
right you know there wasn't sure those
hobbit movies are doing okay right are
they
sure sure yeah
they're they're they're doing
but it's one of those things where it's
like there's a you know it's a you know
there there was no you know it's a lord
of the rings game that's not necessarily
a mandate for it to be good for you
certainly not so the fact that the fact
that it is so good
is uh just one more amazing thing about
it kevin thank you so much for coming on
uh middle earth shadow of mordor
thank you it's out on the uh ps4 xbox
one this for xbox one pc and i think
they're our previous gen version they're
coming they're not out yeah i believe
yeah interesting is that now the format
because that's not happening with the
wwe game they're putting out the
previous gen and then like three weeks
later putting out the next gen oh really
yeah yeah i feel like
i don't know it seems like you'd want to
lead with your like real sexy looking
foot right speaking of it just looks
great on pc yes there's
a lot he has a sexy feet
i mean listen i don't want to i don't
want to alarm anybody but let's just
take a look at that bad boy right there
i'm keeping it covered for decency's
sake what side of what size of shoes oh
it's 11
and a half and a half yeah something the
half makes all the difference kevin van
waar thank you very much going on how
wide is it that's what's really
important
what girth this is normal width average
average average width how do you know
have you seen many other fees i'm much
less interested in your foot now chris
wow that was a rollercoaster ride of
emotion you were i've moved past you
because yeah what you were saying danny
thank you thanks coming on kevin i bet
11 and a half as well yeah we should
compare later all right yeah we'll check
it out let's do a little do a little uh
sword fighting with your feet
all right that's the show thanks very
much for watching everyone much
appreciated uh thanks kevin coming on oh
it's my pleasure hallway and uh yeah
same time next week thanks to everyone
in the back josh dan mary who's on the
gym doing a great job right now eric tay
uh i love you guys don't mess up mary
tuesday 2 p.m pacific adios
you